aid workers say health facilities are
being deliberately targeted in
carbo-delgado
and they can't access huge parts of the
province people fleeing the violence in
northern mozambique
can sometimes only get help when they
reach clinics
set up in camps for the internally
displaced the total of health
centers in the province is of 55
and 39 of them they are no more
operational because they have been
vandalized
or they have been burned or they have
been just destroyed
mozambique's government says fighters
affiliated to isil
are operating in parts of cabo delgado
the militant group
staged its first attack in 2017.
since then the attacks have been bigger
in scale and frequency
taking on the army and the time seizing
entire towns
health workers say the humanitarian
crisis is getting worse
the number of cases has gone up there
are many diseases like malaria
we're seeing displaced people from waida
madumbe and makomiya districts
practically the entire northern area
more than half a million people have
fled their homes many of them are now
in pemba the provincial capital they
complain about overcrowding
malnutrition and the constant threat of
covert 19.
living as a displaced person in pemba
moving from one place to another
there are many difficulties problem with
staring over
finding food to eat at least here i'm
getting treated for illness i have
i'm now feeling better southern african
countries
portugal and others in the european
union have offered to help fight the
armed groups
but there has been no official word from
the mozambique government
on the way forward haru mutasa al
jazeera